all right we got one more for you i
wanted to do a little throwback clip
because uh february is black history
month as they say uh that's what i'm
told in my google calendar and we found
this video of morgan freeman on 60
minutes this is about 20 years ago
talking to mike wallace
about
the importance or perhaps the
insignificance of black history month
black history month you find
ridiculous why
you're going to relegate my history to a
month
oh come on what do you do with yours
what which month is white history month
come on tell me well
i'm jewish
okay which month is jewish history month
now there isn't one oh
oh
why not yeah do you want one no no no no
i don't either
i don't want a black history month black
history is american history
how are we going to get rid of racism
unstoppable talking about it
i'm going to stop calling you a white
man
yeah and i'm going to ask you to stop
calling me
a black man
i know you as mike wallace you know me
as morgan freeman you're going to say
i know this white guy named mike wallace
you know what i'm saying
pretty good huh
remember the old days when you could
turn on network television and hear
something that actually made sense um
look we've got a month for everything
there's gay pride month there's black
history month we got months for all of
these things it's all of this sort of
symbolic silliness but the real moment
in that the kernel in that little video
there
is when
morgan freeman looks directly at mike
wallace after he says he's jewish and he
goes do you want one meaning do you want
a month a jewish history month maybe
there is one i actually don't even know
they probably added one since
do you want one and mike wallace is
right no
why would i want one of those man i
don't want that
that tells you all you need to know
these things have nothing to do with
solving the problems we did such a
freaking good job in america of solving
these problems think about where we were
at ten years ago before we let wokeness
and blm and this modern pernicious
racism of the left into the system
when we voted in that two-time black
president
barack obama with hope and change
whether you liked obama or not i mean
america did vote in a black president
how many european countries have black
prime ministers right like we did
something so well
that we are watching a race right now
and morgan's free morgan freeman's broad
point there
is stop talking about it meaning the
more you obsess over it the more you
make it feel real and the more that it
feels real the more people will act on
that fake realism and we'll all walk
around thinking that everything is
racist so that's a great point morgan
freeman doesn't sit down in that
interview and go who am i talking to
today oh it's
it's white anchor mike wallace and i
hope that mike wallace didn't sit down
that day and go who am i talking to it's
black actor morgan freeman no one cares
about this stuff anymore except the
woksters yes
is are there 50 neo-nazis somewhere
yeah there are
there are a couple do they have any
institutional power does anyone give
them the time of day
no should they be allowed to be outside
holding a flag yeah free speech okay
but
we have to get to the point and we were
so close i mean that's really the point
we were so close to getting to the point
where we were post-race and just as we
were there they pulled the rug out and
now made everything about race and we
cannot let that if america is going to
continue
we can't let it win
so that's what our work is and uh i like
doing work